in the continuing huge wins of Donald
Trump's big boy negotiations with North
Korean leader Kim jong-un there's a new
report out from our American
intelligence agencies which says North
Korea is building new missiles American
intelligence sees signs of new missiles
at the same factory that previously made
the first ICBMs capable of reaching the
United States and there was this report
a few weeks ago I told you about which
showed continued activity at a nuclear
research facility but at the time we
didn't know whether those images were
from before or after Donald Trump's
summit with Kim jong-un the new
satellite photos from the last few weeks
remember it's already been six weeks
since that summit it's crazy the last
few weeks of satellite images point to
one to two liquid-fueled ICBMs being
built at a big facility in sanim dong
outside of Pyongyang this is not
suggesting that North Korea is building
nuclear capabilities we don't know that
but it does show that they're continuing
to work on some pretty advanced weapons
even after Trump declared victory said
on Twitter they're no longer a nuclear
threat painted this ridiculously
ignorant rosy picture of the entire
situation and if you don't trust our
intelligence agencies if you've been
maybe brainwashed by Trump mate maybe
you don't trust our intelligence
agencies even Donald Trump's tone
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo said last
week that North Korean factories quote
continue to produce fissile material
used in making nuclear weapons
north Korea has done nothing actually
suggesting they're going to disarm since
the summit which at this point was a
month and a half ago but we do know that
North Korean officials have been talking
about how they might be able to
denuclearize partially and keep some
nuclear warheads off the record so that
it appears as though that they disarm
but actually didn't huge win for Trump
right and meanwhile American
intelligence sees North Korea continuing
work just like they were doing before
the summit and there's actually a second
layer to this entire farce
even if North Korea did quote dismantle
fully they have the knowledge now and
nuclear experts say they could likely
rebuild everything within just a few
but in the meantime they're not even
doing that right a ton of activity
continues to go on and you might be
saying well but but David North Korea
did shut down that one nuclear research
facility the one on the side of a
mountain
well the mountain imploded and the idea
that that is evidence of North Korea's
willingness to actually keep their word
I would love to be wrong about what's
going on here you know that like we're
not cheering for North Korea to maintain
nuclearization I would love to be wrong
but it's increasingly and abundantly
clear that this is what's happening I
wonder what would have happened if that
Trump Kim summit never took place right
would they continue developing their
nuclear weapons yeah probably so it just
goes to show you that nothing positive
really came out of that summit at least
not yet well we don't know that they've
actually stopped in other words Mike
Pompeo says that they're still doing it
they're still actually producing fissile
material which is part of that
development of nuclear weapons what was
this maybe the confusion that Trump
experienced during his Helsinki press
conference where there was just like a
one-word mixup when Kim jong-un said he
wouldn't build new missiles he meant to
say he would it was just like Trump you
just mixed up one word the art of the
deal who could have known that
geopolitical diplomacy with unhinged
megalomaniacs could be so difficult
totally unpredictable now Trump wants to
have a meeting with the Iranian
president to know you'll no doubt talk
about nuclear weapons I just wonder if
he'll be as naive in that meeting as he
once was with Kim jong-un he already
seems clueless because of the
precondition confusion he's having with
Mike Pompeo which we'll talk about on
the bonus show today if only there was
some precedent with North Korea we could
look to like if only they had made
similar promises before and we could
check whether they had a history of
keeping those promises oh wait a second
they did that a dozen times and never
kept the promises